hey guys Pete here so this is gonna be
my mr. robot season 3 episode 5 review
I'll be honest it took a little bit of
time to decompress and think about it
all if you hadn't noticed the entire
episode was set up as a single take our
single shot of course there's editing
involved with it I mean it's not like
there was just one camera that they had
all the actors in the right places and
everything else but I think they'll
probably be some cinephiles out there
that are really kind of complaining
about this because it's basically a sort
of gimmick I think I think people who
really you know know a lot about film
they kind of think that it can be turned
into a gimmick too much and even though
there's a lot of work and preparation
that goes into it it's not enough to
make it an important part of any real
production in that regard I'd have to
say that it worked really well for me
because this is a show that's
continually broken the fourth wall by
having Elliott talk to us so whether you
had all these cuts and different things
and you shortened up some of the parts
that may have been drawn out a little
bit because of the continuous shot I was
on the edge of my seat the entire time I
mean there's basically like three
different stages in how the episode
unfolds and especially during the
Elliott part I just thought it added to
the tension in a great way because we
talked to Elliott Elliott talks to us I
should say and we're watching him deal
with something in real time in the
Angela part of it it was more of a
alright so now we finally get to
understand how much Angela really knows
about what's going on with the dark army
I mentioned in my recap of the last
episode that she sort of just at a level
of religious fervor you know I mean
she's following her great leader white
rose and we saw her have to face some
tough decisions when she gave up that
name that woman's probably gonna die and
when she takes the bag the red
wheelbarrow barbeque bag
it wasn't lunch that was in there there
was something else there and we know
that white rose has Eliot's death as
part of the plan so she may have been on
the verge and Shore may still be because
we saw her run
in tallien at the very end she may be on
the verge of having to decide if sending
her friend over the edge to kill himself
or to kill him herself is this idea that
we don't know exactly what it is that
white rose has fed to her worth that
kind of thing so a lot of stuff happened
but I think it's worth recapping at
least quickly the different things that
went down here of course we could talk
for hours and break everything down but
let's look at the major things that
happen the episode starts out very
strangely like Elliott we don't really
know what's happened since we last saw
him get drugged apparently it's been
three days he's not really sure what's
going on and there's this really nice
sound in the background that accentuates
what he's saying it's like one of those
sounds that you're just not like you
can't put your finger on it where is
that coming from am I the only one that
hears it is it just in my head it's one
of those things right there's a part
where you know a guy speaks to him in
German and from what I understand the
translation is every beginning is
difficult every beginning is a beginning
so Elliot basically shows upstairs at
his cubicle finds out he's locked out
and he quickly understands that
something's wrong he's able to get on
his per B neighbor cubicle neighbor's
computer or find out that his patch
worked the dark army tried to start
stage two earlier in the day and now
they're on their contingency plan
because he was able to stop those at
least temporarily after learning that
though he finds out the reason he's
locked out of a system is that because
they're coming to fire him like Angela
asked price to do and this is where the
long shot the long take was really kind
of effective I thought because we're
watching him figure out what he wants to
do in real time and because there's all
this other activity the people looking
for him his thought process of trying to
go and figure out how he can best stop
them from working their way around the
patch we feel like we're right there
with him we feel like we're a part of
the narrative at least that's the way I
felt he even says to us at one point
don't leave me
stay focused so we're in it together
right and for someone that we know is
extremely paranoid we can feel the
paranoia there's another point where he
says that you know he's trying to calm
himself down he's trying to look natural
and he's talking about slowing down and
it's sort of almost feels like
everything around him slows down like it
doesn't go into slow motion or anything
if I remember correctly but I made a
note that it's he says slow down and the
tension feels like it slows down
I loved the ladies sniffing the white
out and I love how that wasn't the right
choice but he eventually gets back on
and he realizes he's got to go find this
computer it's called an HSM computer if
he's gonna have any chance in stopping
them we get a great scene where he has
to dip into this conference room and
play it cool I don't know what else
you'd call it to buy time so that the
people outside will pass and Shaun from
sales tries to tell him he's in the
wrong place after Elliot puts him off
for a while that he's silent you know he
sent in the email and he's doing all
this whatever and to buy himself that
little bit of extra time he gives us a
great bit of dialogue and it's just one
of those things it works because it's
something that's universal it would work
on anyone it's not anything that he
doesn't social engineer Shaun based on
Shaun he does it in a way of anybody
that has any responsibility and it works
and it's and it's funny for us to watch
it but he manages to get out of there
only he ends up getting seen so he has
to take off to the elevator and then he
has to make some decisions he's no he's
he knows he's not gonna be able to make
it to that hsm computer he summons not
the real mr. robot but sort of like a
ghostly version of him he you know he
picks his brain like what would mr.
robot do basically and he realizes that
that building is gonna come down his
best thing that he can do is get people
out of there before they all die he ends
up outside and Darlene drops the truth
bomb on him about working with the FBI
and this is something I talked about in
my last recap was everybody in the story
at this point thinks they're doing the
right
thing really none of their things line
up with each other except that Darlene
and Elliot both have incentive to
actually stop stage two he also finds
out about Angela's betrayal at this
point but I thought it was pretty
profound that that didn't seem to bother
him as much as it bothered what Darlene
did bothered him like he finds out
Angela has betrayed him but he says the
Darlene but you did too and she makes
the case of why she did it but because
they have that brother-sister bond he
still can't really stomach that betrayal
but we have to also remember here that
even though Elliot's our hero or
unreliable narrator his mental illness
and his inability to have relationships
plays a big part in all of that with
Angela and Darlene not that it means
that they should betray him or whatever
but if they had a different kind of
relationship none of this would be so
exciting to watch
we know that Darlene does care about
Elliot we know that Angela did at one
point Angela seems to have something
that she cares about more and she may
just be naive enough to think that at
the end of the day at the end of white
roses plan that everyone will live
happily ever after it's profound to when
you think about it this is where we
first see the camera leave Elliot like I
said there's some editing in there I'm
sure but we followed him all the way up
until this point and we don't leave him
until we see this crowd of protesters
and someone who's obviously planted by
the dark army there to incite the riot I
think this is an amazing thing too
because they're not all dark army guys
out there there are real protesters that
are pissed off about everything
basically a CNN lays it out for us right
they're upset about this annexation in
the Congo they're upset about this new
currency they're upset about everything
everything is going to [ __ ] after five
nine but the thing that ends up moving
them to actually attack the Ecore
building are people that are planted by
a very powerful man who is just pulling
strings they think they're doing the
all those people think they're doing the
right thing because evil Corp is this
evil empire that needs to be brought
down but they're just pawns in white
roses game at this point
either way the first part where we see
Elliott it's somewhat subdued it's
somewhat psychological gone through his
thought process as he's trying to find
the problem in the code or beat the game
whatever you want to call it whatever
different way you want to describe it
and then it goes into straight chaos and
we find out that angela is waiting for a
call from Irving to find out what to do
he at least explains to her that those
are their guys that's their distraction
and he tells her that he needs her to do
something there's a package outside and
she needs it to Elliott there's no way
that that can happen so angela has to do
it herself she has a problem in the
elevator whenever she drops the
identification card but because those
people that are on her floor are the
ones that are hardcore dark army they
take out the security guard and she's
able to go and do what she has to do and
it's a vicious beat down I think that
was supposed to be something that we
noticed it they didn't just knock the
guy out I mean they were giving him
boots on the ground and I feel like
Angela must have felt something at that
point sort of like Elliott did in the
aftermath like when we see him walking
around and he sees all this pain and
suffering that he causes the thing that
we saw in episode 1 I think this is
Angela's moment where that starts to
happen her eyes their thoughts are only
on what she wants to get from what rose
and there's real consequences there's
real people getting hurt here and I
think that the acting is pretty good all
the way around I mean I know there's a
lot of Angela haters out there but I
think Angela has really emerged as being
a redeemed character so she does what
she has to do in the HSM room there's a
problem someone comes in and sees her
luckily the dark army guy comes in and
she gets maced and like I said she's
probably gonna die as a result of that
and we seen Angela struggle
a little bit later I feel in my opinion
I feel like she did what she was
supposed to do with the computer that
that part is gonna be okay after that
happens we get the one funny moment well
there might be a couple funny moments
but the one funniest moment when she
goes out to meet her the person that she
has to give it to and it's it's our
friend from the red wheelbarrow BBQ in
his hazmat suit course he's eating his
trademark sandwich he gets what he needs
from her and he hands off a bag I've
already touched on the bag so I won't i
won't go into a two-floor but i mean i
think that to me at the time it felt
like he's delivering something to her
that was meant for elliot and it's not
anything good i think that irving on the
phone being upset that elliot didn't
follow the instructions is that nearly
as much about the fact that angela might
have messed up but that elliot isn't
physically there because honestly they
set it up in a way that i mean it's it
was a it was a card that had everything
written now step by step so that a
contingency plan would be that
Evangeline couldn't get to Elliot she
would probably still be able to do it
there you didn't see a lot of stress I
mean as far as the time and the
destruction that was going on she didn't
seem conflicted or confused about what
she was supposed to be doing there
either way it does seem that
everything's in place for stage two to
happen will the building actually come
down is I feel like it's probably going
to I think the evacuation is the tricky
part let's not forget that Elliot when
he went outside he did call them and say
that a bomb was gonna go off I thought
it was pretty funny in that exchange
when she said oh we don't use ups and
you know he was but you can't just call
a place without them following up on it
I don't think whenever there's a bomb
threat so I think that there's a pretty
good possibility they could roll out of
there but I don't know I've already
taken a look at the the trailer and I
made a videos that you know where we had
some questions because it's the shortest
teaser that I've seen for the show and
we don't really get a lot about what's
going to happen except for it's still
going to continue I think in that they
kind of give you the idea that
there's it either did happen or it's
going to happen but at the end of this
episode we really don't know the last
thing we see is that when Angela goes
back to her office
Elliot's there and he says is there
something that you want to tell me and
that's a conversation that is going to
be tricky because I think that Elliot
should be the one who has the advantage
there but everything that's been going
down has been leading to Angela having
the upper hand in that relationship plus
she knows that she can drug him out and
get mr. robot that and that could that
could that's how it could be in the red
barbeque bag it could be that innocuous
or whatever it could just be a syringe
with that so they can get mr. robot back
or whatever but I don't know I just
thought it was a great episode there
weren't too many prowlers a couple
things that could have been a little bit
better but like I said I thought Portia
Doubleday did a great job doing the mace
you know being mace put in the mask on
even with the mace going to bat doing
what she had to do but also giving us
the feeling that this is bad news this
is bad stuff that I'm doing and I hope
it's all worth it in the end when she
gives the name I mean I think that was a
really powerful scene because the woman
was just run it ran in there because she
was scared and you know she was nobody
but she's gonna have to be killed
because she saw her so yeah I think it
took a little while for me to process I
highly doubt that we're gonna see an
episode next week where it's gonna be
one single shot like it was this time I
think we're gonna have a lot more of
that conflict in between what all the
characters are doing but I'm loving
where we ended up so far I think that
most of the stuff that happened in here
was technically believable I know Korra
Donna was one of the co writers of this
episode I liked how we saw Elliot being
able to use this the immense size of
evil Corp against it I loved the Shawn
from sales thing wheelbarrow BBQ guy
being out there and it was just one of
those things at the end you're just like
gosh I I need a rest I need rest to just
think about all this now it'll be it'll
be interesting to see where things land
now that Elliot knows that the two
people that really
that he trusted in his life have been
actively betraying him in the same way
that we have known that and I imagine if
Angela was able to keep mr. robot around
for the entire weekend
that she'll be able to do that as long
as it's necessary and of course we saw
him in the next trailer so let me know
what you guys think
check out my quick trailer kind of
question video that I made it's so short
I don't think I can make an actual
trailer breakdown please like this video
if you enjoyed it subscribe to my
channel if you have not already please
check out my patreon and think about
joining us over there follow me on
social media that's the easiest way to
get a hold of me I interact with people
on Twitter all the time and I also keep
an Instagram and Facebook page
if you're someone who has a background
in film tell me what you thought about
that tell me what you thought about that
long shot that one single shot kind of
feel I read a couple things briefly in
you know reviews and things and it
seemed pretty 50/50 well it seemed like
it was 80/20 maybe I read one where
someone just said it was horrible but
that always is the case I guess when
you're dealing with critics most people
seem to like it and I think you know it
really does work because we're invested
in our relationship with Eliot and
following his thoughts so it was neat at
least in the first half just to be
watching him go through all that stuff
in real time with the immediacy of like
he can't just go home and think about it
and sleep on it or whatever you know
what I mean like he has to do all this
stuff in real time so that's it for now
guys thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon